[Music]
our next case takes us to Columbus Ohio
where a former vice squad detective is
on trial for a second time after killing
a sex worker and he claims it was
self-defense now this week the crime
scene was laid out for the jury as they
went for a site visit and heard opening
statements from both sides now here's
what we know in 2018 investigators say
Andrew Mitchell picked up the victim
23-year-old Donna Castleberry in an
unmarked squad car Mitchell tried to
arrest Castleberry who engaged in sex
work in the area but Castleberry wasn't
convinced that Mitchell was actually a
police officer based on his lack of
identification investigators say that
there was a scuffle inside the car
Castleberry slashed the defendant's hand
with a knife and that is when police say
Mitchell shot Castleberry three times
she was later pronounced dead at the
hospital this week the jury visited two
sites connected to the case one the
impound lot where Mitchell's vehicle was
stored two along with the actual
location of the crime now this followed
opening statements where audio was
played of the moments leading up to
Mitchell opening fire on the victim
let's take a listen
ing
is
yes
[Music]
don't put your hands on me don't put
your hands on me do not put your hands
on me do not put your hands on me
don't put your hands on me
she's got a knife
[Applause]
yeah
he's coming
we understand officers generally
confront a threat
but their circumstances where officers
are tasked
with saving lives with assessing with
reassessing
with taking measures to avoid taking a
life
he had the ability to create distance
from her she was in the back seat
trapped in that vehicle he had a door
open You're Gonna Hear upon realization
that a warrant check was going to be
done the escalated the situation
escalated from non-compliant to Violent
in a matter of seconds
Donna Castleberry pulls out a knife
you're going to see that knife it is not
a small knife
she attacks my client with that knife
she feloniously assaults my client with
a deadly weapon when he is buckled into
that driver's seat of the Mitsubishi
Terry we often see or hear body cam
footage after police shootings what type
of impact you think that this audio is
going to have on the jury well I think
the jury is going to take a couple of
things away from this audio that they
heard today so frankly I do believe what
stands out to me is she said she didn't
believe he was a police officer that was
very sincere and I think that the jury
heard that and they probably are
believing that she didn't think he
didn't have a badge so that was
something that she thought she also said
help me she rolled down that window and
she looked at a stranger and said please
call the police one of the things the
defense said was that she was trying to
evade arrest but she's not trying to
evade arrest if she's asking a stranger
to please call the police she was in
fear of her life and then ultimately the
last thing in the prosecution hit on
this was she said I'm sorry she was shot
she said basically she was I think at
that point not able to do anything and
he could have stopped instead he shot
multiple times and three of those
bullets actually hit her and it was I
think excessive force well let's be
clear Brian the defense is arguing this
was a lawful arrest he engaged in
self-defense but did it sound like a
lawful arrest to you or and if it wasn't
what happens then Jesse I've rarely if
ever heard of an arrest where an officer
Parks his vehicle in a way that one door
is blocked off so the person can't
escape and then for whatever reason that
person was not patted down not search
for weapons not handcuffed my
understanding is the proper paperwork
wasn't even done he this is either the
worst arrest ever or this was not a
lawful arrest this was a John meaning a
man who purchases sexual favors from a
woman taking advantage of a woman then
using his badge to cover it up and it
seems more like the second one than the
first one and he's claiming self-defense
even though his unlawful act should not
afford him the ability to use that
defense all right weird case weird case
Twisted case and now I'm having a second
run of it we'll see which way it goes